What's the answer? If B is the resigner,
we don't really care about the other column anymore.
>> Mhm.
>> Then what's going to happen is A is mixing between resigning and holding.
>> Yap.
>> And probability P is a probability of being a holder,
so whatever P, whenever that event happens it gets ten, and
whenever one the opposite of it happens it gets minus five,
so I want to say ten p plus one minus p five.
>> Okay,
is that your.
>> Let me try that again.
>> Is that your final answer?
>> Ten p. Well I could simplify it.
>> Okay. Well then say it to me again. I'll write it
out here so it's easy for you to see. Okay and that is.
>> My answer?
>> That's fair. Do you want to simplify it? You don't have to.
>> Sure, let me simplify it, so it's a minus minus
p five and a ten p so that's fifteen P minus one.
>> Minus what?
>> One.
>> Five.
>> Uhun,
there you go. Thank you.
>> That's correct. We would obviously accept either
answer or any combination of those letters. That, [LAUGH]
>> No, I think I might have to do this quiz over actually.
>> No, not the one. I'm talking about either 15 p minus
five or ten p minus one minus p times five. Or ten
p plus one minus p times minus five. Or any other combination
that we can get push car to actually Bothered to, you know.
>> Check.
>> Im, Implement or check. Okay. Well, that was pretty good. And this,
of course, is exactly the expected profit. As you put it, P
times A as a holder and P times or P percentage 1
minus P percentage A chooses to be a resigner. And so it's
just the weighted average between those two values. So, Kent, let me
just double check that. So, if P is 0, that means it
never holds, it means it always resigns and it gets -5, so
that's right and if P is 1, means it always holds, so
it should get a +10. And 15 -5 is 10. So, boom!
>> Yeah,
it works. You used math there, very good. Okay, what about B?
>> B. So the same story, except on the seer side.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So yeah, I might need that space again.
So 5, oh I see, right, minus 5 times p.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Plus 5 times 1 minus p.
>> Mm-hm. If we simplify that we get.
>> There's a minus 5 and another minus 5. So we get minus 10 p.
>> Mm-hm. Plus 1.
>> Plus what?
>> Plus 5.
>> There you go. See you learned. Okay you want to check it?
>> yeah. Oh, that's a good idea. So again if P is 1, then that
means you're always which should be the minus 5 and if we put in a 1
there, we get 5 minus 10 is minus 5. And if P is 0, that
means that we're always a resigner, and we should get a 5 for that. And yeah,
so we zero out the negative 10 and we get the 5.
>> Exactly.
>> Now, it's not clear to me why we're playing this game. Oh, it is clear to
me why we're playing this game, because we
want to figure out something about. Strategy that is mixed.
>> Right.
>> So this is how well a mixed strategy does, but
not against another mixed strategy.
This is against two deterministic strategies.
>> But is it, Michael? But is it? So
>> I'm going to, oh, okay.
>> I'm going to notice something here, which is that you,
as you astutely pointed out earlier, we have two functions. Of P or to
equations of P, and by the way, do you know what they are? They're lines.
>> Sure, because it's just a, it's linear in P, so that's what linear means.
>> Right, so what would happen you, do you
think if we were to actually draw these lines?
>> I think we'd have two lines.
>> Yes, and what would those two lines
look like? Let's take a look, shall we?
>> Sure.